die haben völlig frei völlig ohne Angst
gezeigt dass sie meinen Vater entführt
haben das so so so ist das Regime dass
sie keine Angst haben müssen dass der
Minister des das Geheimdienstes in einer
in aller Öffentlichkeit kommt und sagt
wir haben jumpsychamat in einer
komplexen Operation in den Iran gebracht
dass Sie das sagen können und nicht zur
Rechenschaft gezogen das wird niemand
hingeht und sagt was habt ihr gemacht er
muss frei gelassen werden ich meine wir
sehen jetzt das ist jetzt eine Reaktion
von unserer Bundesregierung gibt nachdem
er das Todesurteil bekommen hat warum
gab es diese Reaktion nicht schon vor
zweieinhalb Jahren als ein Deutscher
entführt worden ist warum war das nicht
schon anders genug um da um da
Konsequenzen zu zeigen das es ist
einfach alles viel zu wenig und viel zu
spät
[Musik]